Done done. Done. Ladies and gentlemen,
one of the greats. Jim Gafcon. Hi Sir. Thank you. Thank you.
It's great to be here. Great to see you, man.
I'm excited that you're doing a special on Amazon. Yeah.
I think it's important that there's a,
a bunch of other platforms for all of us to do specials on.
And when a guy like you goes over to Amazon legitimizes it. Makes it a big deal.
It's exciting. Yeah. It's uh, it's fascinating how the,
the outlets for specials has changed so dramatically because when we were,
when we were kids it was just HBO. Yep.
And then comedy central when, uh,
our release beyond the Pale, it was at that perfect moment where, uh,
in every dorm room in America, comedy central was on. Yup. You know,
it had shifted from MTV to come to central probably cause of Chappelle and,
and John Stewart. And so, but it shifts, you know,
it's like the Netflix was big and um,
and we see these other platforms coming out. So it'll be,
it'll be interesting if I can convince people,
cause everyone goes to Amazon or someone in their family does.
So if I can convince them the next time they're buying paper towels and socks to
just go over to prime because they, everyone has a prime membership.
That's the weird part about it. Right? It's like, it's shopping,
but it's also like the same as iTunes. It, yeah. People have asked me,
they're like, what if, uh, you know, one person asked me, they were like,
what if someone doesn't have a prime membership? And I'm like,
then they're probably not on the internet, you know, who are you? Right.
They probably can't afford even a, you know, high speed Internet.
So it's like, but I don't know. It is going to be interesting.
I've watched stuff on prime, but it's like,
it's like every time you, you know, I think comedians, we like the,
we like to explore and do things different. You know, even, you know,
new rooms and stuff like that. We, we kind of are risk averse,
but there is always the possibility of like, I don't know,
I mean it comes out Friday. Um,
there is some support, but I don't know.
And I know that Amazon is this enormous company, but I don't know. I don't know.
They could, I mean, in the grand scheme of things, you know,
my special is really not that big.
It's not as important as the toothpicks they sell on Amazon.
So I don't know if they're going to get behind it or not.
It's so weird that it's an entertainment company and also a massive shopping
outlet. I mean, it's huge. It's two giant things.
But they do support like Mrs Meson. Oh yeah. That everywhere. Yeah.
So if they have a hit, they will get behind it and make billboards and,
and I've see a lot for a fleabag as well.
I've seen a bunch of ads for that,
so I think they're really picking up their support.
But I haven't seen any support
so far for how many specials are there that they've done besides your,
yours comes out Friday. Mine comes out Friday and then, uh,
a week later there's four that come out
[inaudible] boat and has one coming down for sure. And, uh,
there's three other people with him. And then, um, I don't know. They, you know,
there's also something of, uh, you know, the, the free,
the flow of information is an as,
as dynamic as you'd imagine. Cause I'm like a nerd for like,
if people follow me on Instagram, they're probably like, yeah,
we know you promote. So it's like,
I'm not shy about saying I'm coming to Atlantic City and, uh,
so I'm like, Hey, when is this going? You know, what do you, how can I help?
And there to like, uh, there's a little bit of an attitude of like,
we've got it, you know what I mean?
We know all the information there is, or they don't care,
but I'm not sure. Yeah, I think they're probably overwhelmed. Right.
It's probably a new thing or they just, you know,
some of how it was explained to me was I released a no belay my special before
this, uh, independently, you know, through a lot of different plants.
Why did you decide to do that? Well, some of it was,
I got an offer that was attractive. Uh, I knew that,
I mean, I, I love Netflix. I have five specialists there. Uh,
but I kind of looked at Netflix,
I always described it as it's a, it's a swimming pool. Swimming pools are great,
you know, a special having a special is kind of like a floaty,
but like Netflix, there were just hundreds of floaties in this,
in this pool. So how do you know people are going to watch yours?
You get like a week at Netflix, uh, for, for accessibility.
And I also thought that, uh, it would have a greater impact internationally.
I don't think it did for me personally. Um, and,
and it was something to try differently. You know,
it's weird to is you never really know what the numbers are. No,
you don't know them, they don't tell you, you don't know the numbers.
And it also shifts like, so like the,
the great success that Segura and Allie Wong had.
And you know, like we're Comedians,
we watch all of the specials on Netflix.
I mean, whether we watched the whole thing is another thing, right?
That's like with Ted Alexandro and I were always like, I'm like,
did you watch it? And he goes, I 10 minutes. Did you watch that?
It's like the best compliment is I watched the whole thing.
I watched Chris Rock's whole special, you know, and um,
so I wanted to do something different, you know, I was offered, uh,
and it's, it's, you know, it's uh, you know,
it's expanding your audience and I also understood that a lot of people consume
things on demand. Like I have young
kids, so I'm just, I'm still buying on iTunes. Like it's 1981,
you know, and people consume things on demand. I was convinced on that.
And so it went a,
we did this kind of like everywhere button at flicks and then there was a second
window that was on Amazon prime and it got a real,
a lot of viewers.
And so that prompted Amazon to approach for this special.
So independently, when you released your last one,
did it like a production company come to you and say, Hey Jim,
this is what we want it. Yeah, it was comedy dynamics. And they were like,
we're going, we're going to distribute it, we're going to sell it piecemeal,
different places. And so I was like, yeah, you know what I wanted on, uh,
airplanes and I, you know, I have net flexed but not everyone has Netflix.
And also, you know, the swimming pool metaphor, it can get Kinda lost in there.
So yours was available on Apple TV? He was available on everything.
It was on available on everywhere. Yeah.
And it was even in theaters to get a sense of the numbers from them. Oh yeah,
definitely.
So the Netflix is the only one doesn't give you the numbers that yeah,
supposedly Amazon will give the numbers. Supposedly.
I think they would you gotta get in a room with them. I think that they, um,
you know, it's, it's gonna be so interesting cause I have no idea.
But I also, you know, just as how we consume specials has changed.
I think that, uh, you know, getting,
I think specials serve almost the very personal for us. Right. By the way,
your last one was great. Thanks. But it's very personal for us,
but it also indirectly serves as like an infomercial for our sense of
sensibility. So it's like you want other people to see it so that they can go,
yeah, I liked this kind of stuff.
And so the appeal of it being in different places was appealing to me.
Yeah. I liked the idea of it too. I mean,
I really do enjoy that Netflix has gotten so big in the standup specials because
they've given so many people opportunities and expose the world to so many great
comics. I don't like the fact they don't give me the numbers.
That's a long ongoing, but I do like the fact there's other options now.
I think it's great. And I think, look, HBO now has a streaming option. You know,
they're trying to get really behind HBO go and hopefully more people do that.
So HBO specials will be what they used to be used to be.
If someone got an HBO special, like Holy Shit, it would transform their lives.
Oh my God.
Like Kennison and all these different people we found out about them because of
the HBO. Yeah. I think it's, it's going to be interesting. I think that,
uh, you know, seeing what Disney plus does and seeing, uh, you know,
HBO Max and Apple, but it's, I had, I had approached, um,
Amazon back, I think with my special obsessed,
I wanted to do it on Amazon. They had prime at that point and I was like,
I'll give it, you give me this amount of money and you guys own the special.
And they're like, at that point, they weren't, you know, there,
there were a packaged goods company, they're like, no,
we'll give you 6 cents for every view. And I'm like, no, no, no.
You don't understand.
I'm going to drive people to amazon.com. And they're like,
Nah, we're not interested, but, so it'll take some time. So yeah. You know,
we might think that apple and Disney will step up immediately for comedy
specialists, but we don't know. We don't know.
I think in the future there's not going to be anything on live television except
sports. I really, oh yeah.
I definitely TV like the idea of like tuning in at eight o'clock on Tuesday
night and I was the only time to see something. Yeah,
no appointment television is absurd.
That's a great way of putting in appointment television. It's just, it's insane.
Yeah. No Lee's date. And that's one of the other great things about Netflix.
Like when stranger things comes out, you get the whole damn season. Yeah. Yeah,
definitely.
And so like the bingeing thing is really,
it's absurd. Like there's, there's gotta be some consequences of that.
Cause yeah, it's unhealthy. We're just not getting enough sleep. Now,
this life friend of mine,
she told me that she was up watching stranger things till six o'clock in the
morning. She had to get up at 10 to take your kid to school. Yeah.
It's just theirs. And we binge it like,
like there's some reason behind it. There's dress convenience.
Just get obsessed. I want to find out what's next. Oh yeah.
They left me hanging next. And you're like one more just one.
And those suckers that would wait. You know, like a,
we have my family, I don't want to sound too macho,
but we watched Jane the Virgin, cause my, uh,
teenage daughter was really into it. So as a family we watched Jane the Virgin.
I don't even know what that is. It's a TV show. It's amazing. And it's, I mean,
it's one of those things where my family would be watched again and I would come
in and I would kind of criticize it and then after like two episodes,
I was like, move over. It's totally, it's a telanovela.
It's about Hispanic culture. It's, it's great. [inaudible] Virgin, what's it on?
Great performances. It was on the CW. I don't,
I feel like in my adult lifetime,
the CW appeared and I still have never watched this show on the CW.
Like, have you ever watched the show on the CW? I don't believe so. Right.
It's a real network. Yeah. But it's like be, yeah,
I think the WB was, I think the CW is [inaudible]. Right.
There was a few of those little fringe networks way back in the day.
Like I remember the Wayans brothers had a TV show on one of them. Yeah. There's,
it's one of those weird networks that was, I think it was owned by CBS,
but they're like, it's just kind of like, uh, uh,
you know, like it would be teen shows, like teen romance shows.
And you liked this show, Jane the Virgin. I liked it. I liked,
you know, I'm not ashamed to say it.
I feel like if I asked myself six months ago would I be on Joe Rogan's podcast
saying that I like Jane the Virgin? I would say no, of course not.
Well I remember when, you know,
people used to think that being on one of those networks wouldn't do you any
good when those little small networks,
but then true TV put on impractical jokers and those guys are selling out
arenas. Amazing. That fucking show is so crazy popular.
It's, you know,
it's fascinating watching that show because I, you know,
you're trying to understand it because, but I think it's the authenticity. Yeah.
Those guys, they're pals and it's not manufactured. Right. And,
and I think people like that. Yes. It's very appealing. You're like, you know,
and I think that's also like real guys.
I think there is so much beautiful people that we consume so,
so much beautiful people that were shocked when we see a regular looking person,
we're like, wait a minute, what did that person, that person must be a bad guy.
I used to have a joke about them.
They seem like you could hang out with them too if they seem like regular guys
that would be fun to hang out with. It's like, oh, I want to be with them. No,
look, when I first heard the premise I was like, oh this is, but by the way,
it's been going on for a while,
quite awhile and I was doing shows in London and we have the same agent and they
were doing an arena three nights in a row and London.
It's crazy. Crazy. It's amazing. Like who the fuck saw that come in?
When I heard about it from Ari Arusha,
fear was telling me that these guys were selling out theaters. I was like,
really? I'm like, God, that's incredible. I go, how big?
They were like 5,000 people. I was like, what? Yeah,
what and that was years ago. Now it's, they've moved to arenas. Yeah. And,
and they just keep going and they have like a whole multimedia show. Right.
Let's show videos and all kinds of crazy shit. And they interact with it.
And they're also like, they're still the same guys. Yes.
So they were always those guys. Yeah.
It wasn't like a some cute boy who's trying to act like he's one of the guys.
Right. Look, a record company produced boy band. Yeah, yeah. No,
that's who they are.
Well that's probably why it resonates with people because it is authentic.
I think authenticity is really important.
I think that's what people like about,
I think that's the success of this podcast is the authenticity.
That it's not pre-packaged. There isn't, um, like, I mean,
people that you should understand, it's like even it's, it's a,
it's a weird thing. I don't know.
I don't know if you want to talk about this or,
and that's why I won't talk about that. It's a weird thing to me.
It's an I do it, but like did you,
cause I did this back when it was at um,
the ice house and it's like, oh,
it's amazing. Yeah. It's pretty crazy. It's pretty, yeah. With
the fucks all that are coming. I didn't see it coming. Yeah.
It's like it's a perfect example of doing something on your terms and it working
out.
Yeah, for sure. And also zero promotion of it. I'd never promoted it at all.
I never did any television shows to promote or took out any ads or did other
people's podcast to let people know about it. I just kept doing it.
Always felt like, let me just keep doing it. I enjoyed doing it.
Just keep doing it. And it totally, 100% built by word of mouth.
And so w articles that are written about it, do you read those or no. No.
Nothing. I don't think it's wise because also like,
even generally when there are articles written about Comedians,
uh, you're kind of, there's always like, all right,
let's see what this half day of research,
how they interpret it. I mean, I remember in their body of work in the 90s,
there would be like New York magazine would be like d end of standup con and
you'd read the article and you're like, crowns, I guess. Oh,
they followed that person. They don't even really even do stand up. Uh, um,
so it is, there is no point behind it,
but I'm just kind of a sucker for trying to understand where the zeitgeists is
trying to steer things. But in the end, I think comedy, you know,
Seinfeld describes it as like, it all comes down to butts and seats,
butts in seats. Like they can kind of promote, uh, you know,
like the new best thing. But you know,
those people show up to shows. They, you know,
they're not told where to go.
I think what's also important to note is that the,
is no longer being controlled by media. Like you,
you can't an article in Newsweek or uh,
on a website or, uh, some youtube piece. It doesn't define things anymore.
The, the landscape is too big.
Not No media outlet has any sort of monopoly on how to define someone or
something that the people decide. Now. It's really a meritocracy in that way.
If you, if you have something that's good,
people find out about it and they like it and you can write all your hit pieces
that you want, they don't work anymore. It doesn't work. You know, you'll,
you'll change a few people's minds cause they'll buy into it.
But then if they investigate themselves like, oh,
you're a piece of shit journalists, this is a terrible article about something.
It's,
you know, but I sometimes think, well, like I have two theories on this one.
I sometimes think, was it always like this and I didn't see it?
Or here's my other theory.
My other theory is that in the collapse of traditional media,
meaning the collapse of newspapers and, and just, you know,
television news bureaus that there,
because there's no money to pay, uh,
someone to be, say like a, a movie review. My Wa, my, uh,
father-in-law is,
he used to write movie reviews in Milwaukee and he would review movies and that
was his job.
And that job is really only present in,
in very rare situations.
Otherwise it's just the opportunity of someone that does it out of a passion
thing, meaning someone who has a blog or it's someone who is,
doesn't need a financial incentive. So in other words, they're like,
you've got 50 bucks to write a review of this thing or so it ends up not being
close to objective. Does that make sense? Yeah, no it does.
And I think if you're going to really study something, like if you,
if you want to know about a person, you know,
say if it's a politician or you know,
an actor or comic or whoever you're writing about,
the idea that you're going to figure them out with just a few hours of Google
searching is kinda crazy. It's absolutely crazy.
And the rushes to define someone in either very flattering or very unflattering
ways that this,
that's really where most of the energy goes.
Most of the stories are either hit pieces or they're fluff pieces that seem to
be propped up by a publicist. Yet there is,
I feel as though like I did this movie that came out, um,
it was just a small indie comedy where I was a guy, uh,
who had two separate families and they didn't know about each other.
So it's like he's a good guy now, but he had two families and it's a comedy.
It's set in the 90s. And you know, the,
the reviews that didn't like the movie, that didn't surprise me, you know,
or the criticisms,
but like a lot of the reviews were kind of,
um, there was a tone of like,
how dare this white male have to felt like they couldn't get beyond.
Like, it wasn't like they would insert like, uh,
a social commentary, uh,
onto a platform that was not for that. Yeah. Do you remain like it was,
there was, there was a portrayal of, and there were great female actor,
uh, actors that played my wives and there, there was some reviews there,
like bay under served them. And it's like, you know,
the movie was really about my character and his son, you know, and, but like,
people were frustrated about story. But because of the day we live in,
it had to be kind of deciphered through this,
uh, kind of social, uh,
critique that is just absurd and it wasn't here and there,
it was a lot of reviews like that. Well,
they feel like there's an obligation to discuss that now too,
if they feel like there's some sort of an imbalanced sexually,
like between genders on, on a, on a television show or, or intersectionality.
It's a,
if it has some to do with race or gender or politics or they feel like this is
something that must be discussed.
And one of the things that I hear from friends that, that are,
that are very frustrated is that when they pitch shows,
when they pitch shows to the network, if they have a story, an idea,
like this is what we're trying to, this is the thing. They're like, okay,
where's the diversity? Yeah. I was like, one of the first questions,
they're like, well, it's about an Irish family that lives in the box. Like,
I don't know what to tell you. You know, it's, this is what the story's about.
Like, well, where's the diversity?
Like you have to insert diversity to meet their criteria.
Like you can't just have a,
you can have a story as long as the person's like,
you could have a story about an h,
a Haitian family and it just be all about the Haitian family.
No one's going to say, well what about white guys?
We need to get some white guy on the show. No,
cause if you inserted the white guys, then it's the white savior story.
So you can't be the white guy. Yeah, yeah.
I just can't wait until we're done with all this. I mean maybe,
maybe it'll be long after we're done wet long after we're dead,
but when there's no more racism and this is no longer a viable storyline and
they'd like, no one gives a fuck if you're Chinese or India or from Pakistan,
we legitimately don't care.
They're just different varieties of people and there's no judgment whatsoever.
I can't wait for that time. But until then,
we just have to deal with these observed people that pedal in this narrative
that you have to have, you know, x amount of what?
Like I was reading something where someone was saying that I should run for,
uh, I should, uh, moderate the presidential debates about NBA man,
someone's, it's never gonna happen to them all smoked pot before.
Sure isn't ever going to happen. But someone said,
why do that when you can give it to a talented black woman? I'm like, okay,
I'm out. We're out. We're not talking to, by the way, here's the thing. If,
and I think you'd agree with me,
I do think there's an imbalance and we do have to correct it.
And I do think that like, uh, you know,
and it's great that we have the knowledge and the foresight,
but humans were just clumsy. Yeah. We're just clumsy, you know, with,
um, you know, we're just like, oh, let's just stick this here. When,
when, you know, creativity is much more complex than that. Like even,
even any comedian, we could have Cara top here.
There's a nuance on every joke he does. Like,
people can sit there and be dismissive, but like, he's like, you know what,
I can't do that joke before I do this joke. Whereas people just think it's like,
no, just stick this in there, stick it speech in there.
But I almost feel it's like when greenbook one, cause I saw it after the fact.
I was like, cause you know, like there's this, this belief of, Oh, you know,
you, if you play a a disabled person, you win. And,
but it's much more of like that movie winning was like, Oh yeah, you know,
it's, it's, you know, the great crime of America and race.
So it brings that up. It also deals with, uh, you know, uh,
homosexuality and like the struggle of that, which is profound.
I can't even contemplate it. But it's like, that's why the movie won.
And it was also, we love Italians. America loves that. You get to talk.
Lacey, who doesn't love that America loves Italians. They love Boston.
And you know, that's, you know, that's,
there's certain things that America loves. So I was like, oh, that's why at one,
I'm not saying it's a bad movie. I'm not saying Vivio wasn't great.
I'm just saying that's why I won. Yeah. And it's weird.
It is a little weird. But on the other hand,
one way to look at it is the like design the idea that there can be no darkness
without light, right? There can be no,
there can be no real appreciation of true diversity without an understanding of
racism like in it to, to have it around in its ugliest form.
It makes you appreciate the people that don't express that, that aren't racist,
that are just even keeled. People that appreciate everybody. Well, you know,
there, there's, there's also this too is that, you know, um,
I tend to lean left, um, pretty uh,
liberal socially and um, but I, and you know,
when Trump was elected and like there was the women's march and all this stuff,
there was this, I had this thought process of like, how do I,
how do I, you know, content, how can I contribute?
How can I help make this country better? Which is sounds grandiose, which it is,
but the thing is, it's like I'm not changing anyone's mind.
I really believe that it's like, and if anything,
I think at my shows it's like people are kind of like a break from it.
Yes. You're, I mean like it's, we're all thinking about it all the time.
They're like, all right, there's a a tariff, a Chinese tariff.
What does that mean? I don't know.
What that means is that our American farmers destroyed what's going on,
but like when they come to my show, they don't want me to rehash it. Yes. Yeah.
No,
I think that's one of the keys to your success is that you provide a vacation,
fun, silly, well-thought-out, comedically, brilliant,
sort of vacation from the also pointing out that humans are,
we're absurd. We're stupid. We are so stupid.
Like we just think humans think we have every generation.
We think we have it figured out. Yeah. That's like the, the,
the sharedness of people makes me concerned. Like,
you know, there were people at a time that were like,
here's how we serve the how.
Here's how we solve the flow is we're going to put these layers on. People.
Trust me, it's working. Like they, they were convinced that would work.
Yeah. Yeah. It makes me wonder like, what,
how we're going to view this generation a hundred years from now or 200 years
from now. Oh, it's going to be fat. I mean, I've got,
I've got a 15 year old who, uh, is so,
uh, my children are, they're
so fascinating. And you live in New York City? I live in New York City. Yeah.
Which is crazy. I, I was,
we talked about this a long time ago that that's a wild place to raise kids.
Is it, I don't know. I don't mean, I feel like there is,
um, there is socio economic, uh, cultural,
more diversity. My kids walking to a subway station. Sure.
Then if we lived in the suburbs preacher, um, and uh, yeah.
You know, it's, you know, they don't have a yard, but like, I'm kind of like,
I dunno, it seems like people that have yards,
they're like paranoid about their kids getting snatched anyway. So, uh,
but I dunno. It's what I also, you know,
I feel like there's a lot of convenience in New York that I like and I also,
to be perfectly honest, it's like in La,
I feel like I feel kind of smothered by the entertainment industry and maybe
it's my insecurity, but it's like, no, I think you're right.
There's like you drive down the street,
they're selling these billboards and each of those billboards is saying you're a
failure. Look at this person, this person,
this is their fifth show where they're going to get an Emmy nomination and
people don't even know your name. Yeah. You know, so it's,
I mean obviously just fate had it where I stayed in New York because there's
plenty of reasons to live in Atlanta.
Foremost, you're a comic, you always recognized as a comic,
but you do a lot of other things as well. But like being a,
you do a lot of other movies and television shows and stuff,
but being in New York City,
I think in some ways you get the best of both worlds because you get in many
clubs to perform in many clubs to practice in.
But you also don't get that sort of scrutiny of the the agents and the managers
in the entertainment industry, so you can work on your shit.
And then on top of that, you're not surrounded by the business. Right. You're,
you're around fucking regular folks just hustling and doing your thing. Man,
I'm traveling
blink constantly too. So it's, but there is, yeah, I just like do it. I mean,
here's where I think I'm doing the doing it wrong or doing it right.
It's like I just care about good stage time,
quality stage time. Whereas I think, uh,
you know, even, you know,
like I don't work at the cellar in New York City and that's, you know,
some of that goes back history,
but like some of it is I just want stage time and I can eat dinner with my kids,
put some of them to bed and decide to do a spot, go do the spot,
come back and wrangle my two other kids to get to sleep.
Whereas, uh,
if I went to the seller or if I had to make the journey,
the drive in La, it would be a different commitment.
Let's think about the seller that makes it more difficult. Well, you know,
some of it is his peers and friends. Like I don't like the idea,
you know, the hierarchy of, I always kind of get, you know,
a little bit. Look, I'm just kind of like, I just want to do, stand up.
I just want to do it. Uh,
I spent a lot of time hanging out in comedy clubs and some of it is like in at
the cellar. I don't want to bump some of my friends that I started with. Right.
And I also don't want to get bumped by somebody else. It's like I, you know,
I, you know, I'm not gonna abuse doing a set,
but I'll go in and I'll do 15 minutes and want disrupt anyone's night.
But I also know that at the cellar, you, you know,
there's going to be people that show up.
Sometimes there's a pack of three or four people that are going to do sets and
everyone's kind of off, uh, for that night. But also it's,
you know, it goes back like 20 years ago. I'm a low energy kind of comedian and,
uh, it used to, you know,
I used to put in avails at the cellar and it would kind of determine,
I would get, you know,
like you get a spot Wednesday at 1:00 AM and so like,
I would be bummed for the week. So I don't want to,
I don't want to give my power away in know situation. I just want to do,
stand up or just do [inaudible] gossip. Yeah. And, and also great.
And I, and I, look, I love this Heller, but I feel like that's also, uh, the,
the layout of the room is far more interactive,
whereas I want to try out material. Um, but I dunno,
it's shift. It's shifted because the seller is,
it's a great club with a great complex. I mean there's three rooms,
so, but some of it is,
I'm now at the point where I just wanna do one set and I also don't want to,
like, I don't want a friend like Todd Barry looking at me like,
you're bumping me dry man. Do you call in or do you just show up? I call in,
so I'll call, but sometimes I'll decide at like eight,
10 I'll call Gotham and I'll go, is that okay if I come in and they'll say,
yes,
it's better if you come in at eight 40 or nine 10 just so that I don't screw
anyone up. And then, you know, but like a Gotham Seinfeld always goes there too.
So it's like, I'm like, I got to get there before Jerry.
Well, that's the beautiful thing about a big city like New York,
particularly about New York. There's so many different options.
Like in Los Angeles, we really only have the comedy store, the Improv,
the laugh factory, and then the, there's a few on the outskirts,
but New York City has so many more options. It's amazing
the transformation the comedy store has gone through. Yeah.
Look it is the,
I would say it's probably one of the most important clubs in the country beyond
a doubt. Maybe I'm thinking it's like up there,
right as like the sure fire thing. If you're an audience member,
you go to the store, you're going to see a great show,
but like 15 years ago, I don't know if that was case. No,
no, it wasn't the case in 2008 yeah,
it was [inaudible] who was responsible cause that that comes down to management.
That has a lot to do with it. It also the Internet,
a lot of us talking about how great the comedy store is also getting rid of the
old management, firing them. Right.
They found the old guy was running the place was stealing money and they fired
him. If there's, how many is a piece of shit. Anyway,
it was just so many stories where it's like,
and then it was revealed they were stealing and you're like, yeah, no, they,
they, they did a sting operation and caught him stealing money. Oh yeah.
It was bad guy. But just running the place poorly too.
And he was the reason why I was in there for seven years. Yeah. Yeah.
So I came back and you know all the talking about the store with comics on
podcast to get people so excited about it and then you'd look at the line up
like on a Tuesday night. It's just a murderer's row.
And also those rooms are great.
[inaudible] layout of the rooms are like great for performing.
They're not kinda like this, you know, like I love Zany sense Chicago,
but it's like,
it's not like the stage is three feet higher than the audience is.
It's almost perfectly designed and laid out. Yes. Yeah. Yeah.
You don't want to be above like the, the store,
like the original room is probably the best room in the world to figure out if
your jokes are any good. Yeah. Cause if,
if you have any weird fat in your material or just extra words or fakeness or it
just gets exposed in that room. Yeah. I love,
I love going to different places and I call it purifying a joke.
Are you doing spot tonight? Anywhere now? I'm a probably not. Come on down.
I'm an old man. Get the fuck Outta here. You're going there? Yeah. Alright.
Maybe I'll go. I'm up at nine 30 all right, I'll go. I'll get up here.
I'm going to go and pump you up. I'll call in for you. I'll make you bump me.
Ah, yeah. I mean it's just,
I've been doing this, all this promotion for this Amazon prime thing.
There's so many shows, like there shows that I'm like, I've heard of them,
but I'm like, how many? Like it's, it's getting to the point where people,
like we're doing individual shows for just one person. Like I feel like,
I'm like, I'll do these shows and I'll be like, alright, you know,
and I don't want to name but, but you know,
like I think like I'll look at my publicist, I'm like,
it's their people that listen to this and he's like, yeah, a million people.
I'm like, there's so many people, Jim. That's what it is. It's just,
it used to be the theory, but like,
it's strange to do a show, have a great time, you know,
really kind of engaged in conversation and it drops.
And no one says anything on Twitter or on Instagram or Facebook. Well there's,
if you really stop and think about how many television shows there are in terms
of like shows that you can binge watch, it's impossible.
You would literally lose your entire day every day of the week
just trying to keep up with the hits. There's no way it's impossible.
And then you have how many people have talk shows?
How many of them is James Corden and there's the tonight show and there's Cole
Bear.
Did you want me to not because you used to do those shows. Yeah,
was there was, it's a time management thing.
It's a time management thing and it's also,
I don't believe that they have a good format. I think that format is nonsense.
I think the format of waiting for commercials and the audience being right there
and playing to the audience, it's not,
it's not an effective way to have a conversation.
It's definitely not an effective way to express ideas that are complicated.
You want to be able to like air them out in a long form.
Wang [inaudible] and you can't do that on those shows. You just can't.
It's in it's out. And if any weird or controversial comes up,
you stick your foot in your mouth, you'd never have a chance to take it out.
Nobody really gets a chance to see how your mind really works. Like what?
What are you thinking? What what? Where is your head at?
How do you come to these conclusions? What's your thought process?
Who are you as a person? Are you a good person? Are you trying to do good?
Are you flawed? Are you what? What are you?
And you find that out in a long form.
Conversations like when I had Bernie Sanders on,
one of the things that people said was most interesting.
It's like this guy's not a cartoon. He's a really nice guy.
I see him on these shows and he seems like this fucking cartoonish character.
But now you see him here in this long form conversation where it,
there's no interruptions at all.
He's just has a chance to think and talk and express himself. And he'd go, oh,
now I know the real Bernie because I never knew him in these goddamned debates.
And he's screaming for 12 seconds, right, about healthcare,
about taxes or about whatever it is. Yeah,
it's fascinating. It's like, all right, here, let me, let me ask you this. Okay.
Give me one of them. So let me try that. Beautiful. They're delicious.
I go original flavor. And you used to use to do the chew, right?
I used to tip and then I used to smoke cigarettes. Like there's, my wife has,
uh, uh, videos, like, you know,
we have all these old videos of us doing stand up and she was transferring them
to like DVDs at the time.
Now we're going to have to get them off the DVD and she would find these videos
of me doing standups smoking on stage. Whoa. Back in the day some.
And she was like, what are you doing? And I'm like, yeah, I used to smoke.
I used to, you know,
I had yellow fingers [inaudible] cigarettes before I go onstage. Even recently,
I smoked one of Chappelle cigarettes, uh, last weekend.
It gives you a crazy head rush before you go on stage. I like it. It's,
I want to smoke cigarettes. Sorry for the smacking in the microphone folks.
It's a terrible thing to smoke cigarettes,
but there's a weird rush that you get from, from the nicotine.
I was like a head rush. It's like you feel good. It's fine as you feel it,
you feel it the first couple times and then you're chasing it for the rest of
your life. Well, if you only smokable money into a garbage can once a week,
if smoke a cigarette once we, for you on stage, that's a real,
that hey kids out there. Just listen. Just listen to uncle Joe.
Just smoke one cigarette a week and it'll be fun. Well,
I'm thinking maybe you're nicotine gum might be the a substitute for that.
Cause what I'm getting is the nicotine, right? I mean,
that's what the rash is great by the want to start smoking cigars before I go on
stage. I, uh, I the, the, the nicotine gum,
it used to curb my hunger. It used to curb. Nothing does, ma'am?
Nothing at all. Curves. It's like, but we're talking about this outside.
I'm like, there are times when I've been more in shape than others,
but I feel like at this point I'm like, you know what,
maybe I'll just go in all in and fat guy. I might just be like, you know what,
I'm just, I'm just going to go all in, you know, like, you know, I'll just,
you know, I'll take the place of Pinette, you know, I'll just do that.
You know what I mean? You seem thinner though then I've seen you before.
I'm not, I'm not, I'm not at all, but it's just,
I have low t. I don't know what that even means. Like I'd see those commercials.
Testosterone. Do you take testosterone or take testosterone?
You seem like you'd drink it every morning. Have you ever like,
but like, I feel like I just need like energy. Yeah. That'll give you energy.
Your body's dying and it is dying.
Current system no longer produces the hormones. [inaudible] um,
I mean [inaudible] when you see an older person,
when they have diminished muscle and their, their mass is like shrinking.
That's what's going on.
Their body doesn't produce the hormones in order to keep the mass going.
So which you have to do is two things. One, you have to lift weights.
That's one thing. And two you have to supplement your hormones.
Um, no,
but some of it is I'm so focused on eating.
No, I'm so focused on, I sometimes listen to my set while I work out.
It's like when you work out you have to focus on working out. Yeah.
But that's a good
the thing to do. I do that when I'm on the elliptical.
Sometimes I'll listen to listen to comedy. I think listening to sets is uh,
one thing that not enough comics do.
They record their sets but they don't listen to them cause it's gross and you
feel, oh it's annoying. You don't want to hear it.
But it's way the way you learn. And I feel like, I mean, I don't know,
I would like to know how you feel about this,
but I feel like the amount of time,
the span concentrated on your material has a direct result in how good it is and
how good it gets quick. Especially when you're producing specials,
so you abandoned all your material and then you have to write new stuff. For me,
that process is greatly accelerated by physically writing.
Physically writing is very important. Yeah.
I devote a lot of time to sit in front of a computer, staring at it,
smoking pot, writing things out, looking at notes, writing things out,
performing. Those are critical, but also listening,
listening to those recordings and then writing notes on the recordings.
Yeah. For me the process is it shifts all the time,
right? So there's some times you just give birth to a chunk, it'll [inaudible].
It just comes out and you're like, oh my gosh, thank God.
And sometimes it's just like you're chiseling away at granite and it's just bit
by bit underneath.
But for me it's doing these longer sets,
like doing an hour and 10 minutes.
I will and it's a shift from before it used to be like I needed the sits of sets
in the city to like a build piece by piece.
But now I'm kind of all talk about like something that happened, uh,
when I was a kid and then I'll polish it over a long period.
Cause in an hour show it's, you know,
I believe you have to do a material every time you do a theater and it has to be
new because you want people leaving going, I'm coming back when it comes back.
Yeah. And so, but the writing process, it's, it's always moving for me.
Sometimes it is,
it's a lot of times like something will bump me and I'll write it down on my
phone and then sometimes I'll write around it or I will just go on stage and
talk a little bit about it. Are you, um, when you are doing sets in the city,
are you ever doing long sets? Like an hour?
Not usually because it's, I mean, my, when I'm in New York,
you know, having five kids, it's just,
just the commitment for like, I'm looking at September and I'm like, oh my gosh,
like the,
the curriculum nights alone are going to be insane.
And there's going to be, you know, uh, you know,
my daughter's in soccer and there's going to be all these meetings and there's
just innumerable things. So like assemblies, school assemblies, you know,
like chatting with the principal who talks about their philosophy.
And so like, there's, there's a commitment, but like doing the hour,
I don't really usually do it in New York, but what I do do is I will,
I like to do, uh, I dunno what they're called now,
but all chose in Brooklyn, which is, it'll kind of like,
uh, I'll do material that would work in a comedy club. But like in, uh,
in Brooklyn in front of like a more, I don't know how to describe mortars.
Hipsters are more precious audience, precious dear. I mean, where,
you know, like when I go on stage in New York City in Manhattan,
I'm a white guy who's like fat.
When I go on stage in some of these rooms in Brooklyn,
I'm a white man. You know what I mean?
So it's a different experience and it's very important to see that because how I
characterize things, uh, you know, it's,
it's good to like be educated on like, ah, you know? All right.
Maybe that does sound a little piggy. So I'll pull back. Right, right.
And then I'll go on the road.
Like I used to like a great example is I used to have back when USA,
I'm sure USA today is still there,
but I used to have all this material that I developed in, uh,
in Brooklyn about the USA Today. How like, it's just like a coloring book,
you know what I mean? And how it's just kinda like, do you like news?
But also pictures of news and it was just great and it would kill in Brooklyn
and we would kill in New York.
And then I would go on the road and people would be like,
what the hell are you talking about? And unlike the USA Today,
that's what I get when I travel. You know what I mean?
Or it's got a great sports section.
So it's like there's so much value in traveling around with material cause you
gain different perspectives. Oh sure. The road is so critical for that.
Yeah. Get a sense of how people, especially when you're doing clubs,
I've found that the road, when you're doing clubs,
you really get a sense of like the feel of a city, whether it's Cleveland or,
oh, yes. Yeah. I mean I loved the fact even, you know,
how, uh, you know, doing a, talking about, you know,
I make a point of not doing too much material on having, uh,
five kids. But like I'll do,
like if I talk about having five kids in New York City and at a show in New York
City, people are like, you're crazy.
And then if I talk about having five kids and Boston,
and I'm generalizing, people in Boston might be like, you're crazy.
I came from one of those families, and if I do it in Utah, people will be like,
yeah, we are crazy for having five kids.
So it is the same joke and it's the same point of view,
but it's tweaked a little bit and it's so fun.
Kind of traveling around and learning that material and learning the impact and
how it's digested. Well, comics have a unique
perspective on America because of that,
because we don't just go to these different places,
but we also perform material in all these different places. So I think, like we,
I've been talking a lot with comics lately about like what was your reaction to
Trump winning the election?
Comics sought coming more than most people who live in La because most people
live in la, very liberal, very left wing, convinced that, you know,
this is even, it didn't, it didn't matter who you voted for.
Hillary was gonna Win California no matter what. Yeah. Like we were,
this was a pro Democrat state and when Trump won,
I ran into people that were shell shocked. They couldn't fucking imagine.
I mean I think, I mean I was surprised. I was definitely,
I was definitely surprised. But that being said,
I wasn't surprised by um,
the uh,
the logic behind some of the people that voted for Trump last time that are
sheepish to admit it now. Yes. Um,
I understood some of that logic but I thought it was fascinating cause there was
a time for me, cause I tour with uh,
Ted Alexander a lot and he's like a mock ted. He's like,
he's like an occupy Wall Street guy.
Like he is like a very progressive and we would tour and he would have,
during the election he would have some material on Hillary and some material on
Trump. And it worked everywhere in Texas, worked in Tennessee,
which I think is the most conservative place outside of Nashville. And,
and so it will work everywhere.
And then the election happened and that same material,
and it wasn't just the context of the post election, it was,
I call,
I described it as people looking at the ceiling is that people didn't want to
hear it.
And I think some of it is people like we deal with this all day,
we need a break from it. But it was both sides.
So like Trump voters were more embolden kind of like that's right.
And then also the left people were like, please can I,
I just want to hear Jim talk about horses for 10 minutes during meeting.
And so there is something fascinating that occurs.
And there's also something fascinating about international shows because when
Bush was, when w was precedent,
there were much more people coming up to me going, how dare he, you know,
start the Iraq war and with with Trump, they're like, yeah,
you probably didn't have anything to do with that. Yeah,
I would say that's my takeaway. Yeah, it's,
people are definitely fatigued. I think we have [inaudible],
we have political discourse fatigue. It's neverending,
neverending. And if it's, how much of it is your life,
if you really stop and think about it, if you're alive for 75,
85 years on this planet and most of your waking time interacting with people is
discussing politics,
how much of it actually does affect your life other than those conversations,
those conversations. It's a,
a giant part of a lot of people's anxiety, a giant part of the arc.
But the real life, like getting up in the morning,
fixing breakfast for your kids, taking them to school,
how much fucking Trump play a part in any of that. I did,
I did a CBS Sunday commentary on how all conversations lead to Trump.
Like it's just every conversation eventually gets to,
and then Trump did something like that. But it is,
I was also thinking like, cause we,
we live in this very precarious time and, uh, you know,
a very divided country on a lot of different levels and there's so much drama
and there's, you know, uh, you know,
environmental disaster and pending and I, and again,
to my point of like is we finally figured it out.
This is the most dramatic period, but compared to World War II, no,
this is nothing. Nothing. This is nothing.
I was in central Europe what the, like human beings like we, I, you know,
you know, and we're going around this, uh,
terrorists in this place outside of Prague where they stuck all the Jewish
people and with my children and my children who like just want to play on iPads
were just mesmerized. They're like, what? And,
and the takeaway was not, oh,
the Germans are bad and Nazis are bad. The takeaway is, oh,
humans are crazy.
Like it's just a matter of months that the same people that we're your
neighbors,
that you would go to their kids' birthday parties you were waving goodbye to
because you got their apartment. And I'm like, oh. Like it was terrifying.
Like human beings, it's very easy for us to go. Yeah. It was the Germans.
It was the Germans that did that. You know, it was Lithuanians did it,
but it wasn't, it was human beings that were like manipulated like that.
Yeah.
You catch the wrong leader. Yeah. Yeah. But we're right next to you. That's,
that is a World War II helmet.
That's a legitimate world war two helmet in a bay in that, wow. That uh,
it's a good reminder. It's filled with little holes and shit.
There's apparently places in Europe where you can find thousands of those things
just scattered out there. You know,
there's the areas in France that are impossible for people to go to because
there's so many rounds that have been shot into the ground there and so much
toxic chemicals and stuff from World War II that to this day they don't want
people traveling to, I mean it's an enormous size. The size of Paris.
It's in Braylee. Yeah, see if you can find that.
That's amazing. There's also from the forties,
so like when I was in Prague and you know,
you go on these tours and the punishment,
like they would just be like, and this I also learned this in Greece.
They'd be like, they'd be like, uh, okay.
So as punishment we are gonna murder an entire village.
So we're going to in your look what, and by the way, again,
we can characterize this, this of cause on the internet, everyone's coming back.
Gaffigan was defending Nazis. That's not my point at all,
is just that human beings.
Like it wasn't that long ago when like rape and pillage was the goto tactic.
It's like, all right, we'll conquer then we'll rape appellate. You know,
there were some guys who were like, you know, what can I just pillage? I just,
you know, I got a girlfriend now and I don't really feel like raping.
Well we were talking about Kurdistan the other day that to this day 20% of all
marriages begin in kidnapping. What? Yes,
20% so one out of five marriages started with the groom,
kidnapping the bride.
Like that's how they had to get married because he raped her.
So in order for her, it's romance. It's fucked. Unbelievable.
It's fucking crazy. Here it is.
The Red Zone in France is so dangerous that a hundred years after World War Two,
it's still a no go area.
There's all sorts of rounds and munitions and there's all sorts of, I mean,
there's so many rockets were fired into this area that this shit is still in,
in the soil and everyone,
I, you know, this also brings up a, a separate point. Why,
why is this surprise? Like what
humans also have a really w a real short term memory problem.
Like we don't remember things, right? Like, I don't think people really, uh,
appreciate, you know, that World War II was like 70 years ago,
right? Like, it was not that long ago. Right? Like even the, you know,
like Serbia, I was in Dubrovnik and they're like, yeah, up there,
the Montenegrins used to shoot at us. Now those guys, you know,
now we go to their bar and you're like, what? Like that was the nineties. Yeah.
It's just, it's just terrifying. It's, it's hard to believe,
but if you're in the wrong place in history at the wrong time,
like right now, if you're in Libya, Libya right now, or Syria, yeah,
well, Libya is a failed state. I mean, Syria is horrible.
You got Assad running it, but Libya has no one running it. Libya.
They're selling slaves on youtube. I mean,
you can watch slave auctions in real time right now. It's a terrifying,
terrifying place.
And it's because they killed a Momar Kadafi and then the rebels took over and
then it became a felt a failed state. It's chaos.
And this is right now in 2019 if you were unfortunate enough to be born in
Libya, you are stuck there right now and you're living in hell.
You're not living in Manhattan in 2019 where it's wonderful.
Jim Gaffigan can hop on over to golf. Yeah, hi to Jerry Seinfeld. Do a second,
have a meatball sub and you know, do whatever the fuck you want. No,
you're living in a chaos filled environment where Bob barbarians are running the
show. And this can happen. This can happen.
And this is one of the reasons why our democracy is so important.
One of the reasons why compassion is so important and kindness and talking to
people.
And it's also important to look at things objectively and label things based on
compassion. And, and looking at things in an intelligent,
non-biased way so you can really get a sense of what the landscape really is.
If you're, you know, you're,
everybody's a fucking Nazi and everybody's terrible and white privileges,
white privilege that everyone's a criminal, everyone's bad. No, no, no.
There's real crime in the world.
There's real terror and real awful things and we have more unity.
We have more in common than, than we promote. You know, what I think is,
and I think this is also a reflection of the success of Comedians,
podcasts is that w what people don't realize is that comedians really appreciate
a different point of view. We actually, like,
we have friends that like we don't agree with. In fact,
we almost find it entertaining. Like,
let's talk to this friend because I know I disagree with him and we can have
that banter. And I think that particularly in this, uh,
cancel culture there is. And so like you get these comedians,
like you hosting these podcasts, having these discussions and,
and comedians have kinda like the boldness to step in it and say,
Hey, I don't know about that. Tell me about that, where it's like,
from a societal basis, there's like, don't question,
don't question a why we're pursuing this, because if you question it,
that means you're not a true believer. And we're looking for true believers.
Whereas, and by the way, it's,
it's just interesting because I think, you know,
I have a friend Tom Chaloo who I love who is, who has a show on,
uh, on Fox, uh, nation.
And it is weird cause like six years ago,
and I did this interview and I talked about it and,
and I could see the interviewer go,
you're friends with someone that works at Fox. And I'm like,
yeah, you know, it's like, it's okay. Yeah, it's okay.
He's not a monster. Yeah. He's not killing, you know,
he's not putting children in cages. He's friends with Steve Hilton.
He has a show on Fox. He interviewed Trump by my family and his fan.
Go on vacations together. And this guy, it's like, why?
Like it's, it's,
it's this strange thing where I'm like,
I can understand how important these beliefs are and I can understand how
threatening, um, democracy is.
And I can understand how we have to face our history and, and all these things.
But it's like the discourse has to remain,
doesn't it? Yes. We have to be able to talk to each other.
And I think that's one of the things that kind of died with the Trump election.
People were like, you're with us or against us.
You're the for him or you or your fear for the future and compassion and caring
about everyone. Or you're a monster and there's no,
there's no discussion about finances or the best way to run the economy or
international trade. No, no, no, no, no, no, no. You are.
You're with the good or the bad. You're binary. It's one or zero.
You're black or white. You're one or zero.
And that is the same thing that they criticized about w saying you're either
with us or against that. Which by the way, being a father of daughters,
you know, is also a line from beauty and the beast. Yeah.
But isn't this true? Appropriately so. Right.
It's like very childlike like that. That perspective is very childlike.
There's a lot of people that are conservative that are very good people.
Absolutely. That's, I, you know,
here's another thing that I find very frustrating.
I feel it's though I'm sometimes, and sometimes I'll get, uh,
messages on social media and there'll be like, you know,
that some of the people that like your comedy are Trump supporters.
And I'm like, I hope so.
I hope that I appeal to a lot of different people. Uh, you know,
I, it's, it's a very strange look.
I remember the success I had and I'm so grateful for the success that I've had,
uh, on, beyond the Pale.
I remember it like I came back to New York after I had done this tour and you
don't know with stand up, you don't know how long it's going to last.
You don't know what's going on.
And I came back and I remember someone reading an article,
maybe it was in out in New York and they're like, he's very mainstream,
mainstream. And there was recently in New York Times article,
he is very conventional and I'm like, what is that?
Do you mean like conventional in that people want to go and see me perform?
Like a lot of people like that, like that's a crime. Like that's he's,
you know, he, you know, it's like, it's, so we live in this age,
like there used to be comedians and I think it's inhibited some people's success
where like if it's like bill burr, one of the best comedians today,
and I think people are sometimes people in the media or like, you know,
the wrong people might like his material and you're like,
that doesn't do what I'm saying. Yes, maybe I'm being paranoid, but I'm like,
no, I get that from this podcast. It's, it's a very strange,
it's, it's, it's almost kind of a, you know, and I,
and I don't know if I've talked about this, but like, you know,
like there's this cultural revolution that is occurring that is,
it's well-intended, but it's almost, it's almost puritanical.
And, and by the way, I'm not somebody I'm against any form of censorship,
but I'm also somebody that believes that if we can articulate a transgender
terms that make people that are transgender or feel comfortable, there's,
there's nothing wrong with that. We can adjust our language.
We do it all the time.
But I do think that there is kind of this almost puritanical thing that's
ironically happening on the left. That is what we,
you know, as Comedians we use to make fun of the right four.
Does that make sense? Yes. It's a very strange kind of like, wait,
you guys are doing what you accused these guys of doing forever.
If they don't see it that way because they feel like they're right and if you're
right, then it doesn't matter if it's well intended. I do think it's Wellington.
I don't question someone's motive. So like I don't think that, like,
I remember and I'm going to get blow back on this. Look,
I don't think that w uh, what had malicious intent,
I think he was well-intended, you know, he failed at things,
but I think he was well-intended. I think that's probably a logical perspective.
And I think Dick Cheney's probably Satan. You think so?
I think Dick Cheney was run. I mean straight from hell.
That's why I had that bunker deep, deep down under the,
I think that bunker existed. He was right. It wasn't like, he was like,
it's not like he was like, yeah, I need a bunker.
He had a straight shot straight to hell. That's what it was. It was,
it was down there. That's how it was heated. That's why it was so warm.
That's what he would remember when he was in the bunker after nine 11 there was
like Dick changes in a bunker. How come George Bush is playing golf? W's
is out there. [inaudible] target on the forehead.
He was in DC and there was a separation of, of powers. I Dunno.
And then we all saw the Adam McKay movie. You're like, how much is that true?
I not right. Um, how much is that true? Imagine the power
too, because Dick Cheney, like I, you know,
I also doubt everything I always caught, you know, like everything I hear about,
I'm Kinda like cut it in half,
which makes me kind of still think Trump is absolutely crazy. But,
but like, you know, Dick Cheney is there,
like is he is and I don't think he cares,
but like there's no, like w w the,
the narrative has been set for him. Yeah. There's no kind of like,
you're not going to believe this,
but Dick Cheney is like one of the funniest storytellers. Like that's,
there's no, there's no changing the narrative of Dick Chamie.
Right. Like George W's painting and he does a lot of painting.
Painting is kind of lovely. It's like, it's cute sweet stuff.
It's like good shows you where his mind is at.
This is where he chooses to spend his time. Katrina,
he didn't go there right away. Well,
he hates me on people according to Kanye West. Right.
But Dick Cheney w is a completely different animal.
Like he shot his friend in the face and his friend apologized. Yeah.
But he didn't do it. He obviously didn't do it on purpose, probably drunk.
And then he disappeared for 24 hours.
Do you know that he didn't immediately turn himself in and he won't. Yeah,
he was most likely drinking.
They were doing what's called a canned hunt where they open up these gates and
they let these birds fly out and they just start blasting him and he shot his
friend. But it was, it could've been a mistake. It was a mistake.
I probably have known as the Dick Cheney apologists. Nice.
So explain this Halliburton.
So he was the CEO of Halliburton leaves Halliburton and then he becomes a vice
president and then he gives Halliburton these no bid contracts to rebuild Iraq
after they blew it up. So explain that as a, as a apologist. Um, you know, uh,
I would say one,
a no bid contracts happen often and that's what I've heard.
How can you chew another one of those?
My heart is pounding on my chest cause I'm a real man. I'm more manly than you.
You know, like you're real type A, I'm a real, like I get up.
I do. What are those bells that you kinda sounded the bells. Kettle bells. I,
you know what? I eat a bowl of those for cereal. Nice.
When you're a man like me, that's what I do.
I put CBD oil on my knees and then I just lift.
I lift bulldozers. That's what I do for breakfast.
Then I jog up mountains and just yell and then I just come home and I just eat
elk meat. But you know, unlike you, I don't Cook it.
I just eat the elk when it's alive. Sometimes it's better to cook though.
What is elk meat tastes like and wants them around here? Not really.
You don't care kitchen here. If
I had a kitchen here and I cook some, would you eat something? I'm sup.
We're at this compound. You have this huge place.
You've got a horse track in the back. You don't have a kitchen here.
I'm going to open up a kitchen here. Seriously. I'm actually, I'm going to,
I'm thinking about putting together a restaurant,
so friends come over and you saying what makes you,
maybe you've talked about this and I haven't heard the episode, but elk meat,
is that good or it's just, yeah, it's a wild animals.
What does it taste like? Deer. It feels like deer. Well, venison, you're like,
oh, this is good. You know, if I have really strong mustard and I'm not hungry,
oh man. It's just prepared poorly. This is delicious.
It's all of it is how the meat is taken care of. After the animal dies,
whether it's cooled quickly and how it's processed, that's all it is.
How it's cleaned, how it's cut up,
how it's vacuum sealed and frozen almost immediately after the animal dies.
How you don't let it in the glands.
Like they have tarsal glands that they can get. They have hormones.
Like a lot of times when you shooting these animals, it's during the Rut.
So their, their breeding and this is, this is when they hear,
they get these hormones and these tarsal glands,
they put these any why don't get it on the more out. Why don't we eat more out?
Cause it's a wild animal. It's an illegal animal to sell.
You have to go out and hunt them. You're,
but why doesn't someone just started an elk farm? Because it's,
it's just Ark Eldoret down on those. Well there's a lot of,
there's a lot of factors there. First of all, you can buy [inaudible] lobby. No,
no, no. You can buy it from New Zealand. New Zealand sells a lot of it.
And I think there's some places where you can buy commercially raised elk in
North America. I'm not exactly sure if that's the case,
but it's illegal to sell wild game.
And there's a difference between an animal that's been penned in and force fed
and just, you know, big bales of Hay and whatever,
or a wild ass paper. Yeah. Um,
I'm interested in wild animals because I think wild animals are healthier. Also.
I think the Karma of what you're doing is very different.
You're just going after a wild animal that's in the Rut and they wind up killing
each other. They get killed by mountain lions and wolves and bears.
And what I'm doing is I'm dipping my toe into the natural world and I'm a circle
of light.
I'm going after them the way a mountain line would go after them and she's
choosing a bow and Arrow and I'm getting them to bring it back.
And then I eat that one animal a hope for a whole year. I'll feed my family.
You know, Tom Papa, Tom Papa is a giant consumer read Arabic pop,
let's say with bread out of, it's like,
you wouldn't pop it like at your restaurant. You have to pop it to the pressure.
He'll be the bread man and like,
good for [inaudible] sell the weed and then anybody could tell the wheat today.
Right. I guess anyone could today. Yeah. But uh, but like you love elk,
you wake up and you're like, you know what? I want to,
I had a do you want to from breakfast? Well who doesn't have help for breakfast?
You have the elk. Syria. I had sausage, sausage, breakfast.
And do you make your own elk sausage? No, I get that made.
I get it made by a butcher that I know.
And so do you think that when I come back,
cause I do this podcast every six years.
Do you think when I come back and do it as often as you want? Oh well thank you.
We just didn't have the right phone numbers.
Do you think that we will that uh, what is the,
um,
what is the it do you think that elk is the new Kale that you are going to that
we're going to track it back to? Hard to do. Did to go out and get it yourself?
It's very difficult.
You have to be like really committed to learning how to hunt and then to be fit
enough to climb the mountains and then what do you track it back?
You have to carry it out in chunks. Yeah.
Trop it up and then you carry it out in chunks.
Quarter it meaning you take the legs off and you take the backstraps,
you know that there's like grocery stores for and it does not the survey elk and
it's a different experience.
Why we're saying why wouldn't someone listening to this start an elk ranch and
so that they can sell illegal, it's not legal,
it's not illegal to sell wild game. And then there's a reason for that.
And also when you have these farms,
there are farms that raised deer and some other animals.
There's a real problem with a chronic wasting disease and certain diseases that
get easily spread when all of these animals are eating off of the same food
source.
So if they have like a bin where they're all eating at him and they share,
saliva actually contributes to the contamination of certain diseases.
And there's a real problem in this country with something called CWD,
which is chronic wasting disease.
And it's the same exact thing of is a mad cow disease.
It just hasn't jumped over to other animals. It's jumped over to mice,
but it hasn't jumped over to humans.
But if it did jump over to humans it would be a gigantic fucking problem.
And part of that problem they believe stems from farms,
from farms that are raising deer. It's very controversial.
I mean there's people. Where do you go to hunt elk? Cause we're
different from where I hunt elk. I go to Utah every year.
Go to Colorado is a great place to hunt.
Montana is a great place to kind of l l content area.
Just got to go into your job. You should come with me. You kick out,
you kick out. I would have, unlike you, I wouldn't corridor it.
I just drag it back, throws down strong enough and I'd put some kettlebells on.
Stick your Dick in kiss, carry it out like a condom. You just sit.
So they're big animals. So like if they,
if you missed will they charge you elk? Most of the time won't do that.
But a moose certainly would moose or get into certain nest if fucked you up.
That's the elk right there. There you go. Yeah,
I shot that one in central California.
And so how do you get that on an airplane? Well, you have to a quarter it up,
chop it up into portions, freeze it, and then stick it in like a Yeti cooler.
And then I'll seal the Yeti cooler and you have to bring it through customs and
then they have to, uh, they have to look at it, not customs, but uh, TSA.
They have to open it up and check it and inspect it and make sure it's human.
Yes. Not a human. Yeah. And then they, uh,
they wouldn't really wouldn't know if it was a human, as long as you package it,
you could say it's wild pig idea. Holla.
And so what is that thing there? That is for my friend Adam Green Tree.
That is an easy adic water buffalo that he shot in Australia. Yeah,
he's a buddy of mine. He gave it to me, so I decided to put it. And so, uh,
how many, how many elk have you shot? Like you, you really,
it takes you a year to eat it. Yeah, yeah. About, no,
I can eat one in about six months. My family eats a lot of it.
I give a lot of it to my friends. And Do,
do people's like th or your daughter's like elk again? Sometimes. Yeah.
Sometimes we get annoyed. We eat a lot of meat and a lot of elks do.
And it's healthier than beef. Oh yeah. But why is it healthier?
It's got more protein per ounce. It's got more amino acids. It's,
it's a darker Richard Color.
Like if you look at grass fed beef versus grain fed beef,
one of the things you noticed is the grass fed beef is a darker color.
The meats are dark cars. Just a healthier animal. That's what,
that's what beef is supposed to look like. What don't you eat? Um,
I eat a lot of food. Fast food occasionally. Yeah. Occasionally. Man, I'm not,
uh, I'm not rich. Like I'll eat in and out burger. I love it. Yeah.
I'm not that rigid burger.
Are you imagining that it's an elk burger? No. No. I'm just enjoying it.
Do you consider yourself an elk meat, elk meat advocate? Yes.
You are. Human milk becomes want to convert people? No. No.
Why not buy a ranch? No, no, no, no. I don't want people to buy it like that.
I'm not even saying that you should go out and hunt.
I'm not saying that people should do it,
but what I'm saying is if you did do it,
you'd have a completely different relationship with your food.
When I'm eating something,
there's like a real good feeling that I know that I harvested that thing.
I was out in the woods. I chased it for days.
I was trying to like get the wind right so that my,
the wind is on at my back blowing towards the animal I got to sneak up on.
It's slowly I have to figure my way to where I can get a clean shot on this
animal. Then once I kill it, then we have to drag it out of there.
We have to cut it up and aim for the head or do you aim for the heart game from
the heart. But if you have a high powered rifle, there's a lot of um, um,
people that are chefs that shoot him in the head. There's a,
they think that it's quicker. Like the, if they die quicker, they taste better,
but I, they taste delicious. I don't,
I don't really think there's any need for that. I mean, there's a,
there's an idea that if the animal has too much adrenaline in it,
like if it's spooked, then it will taint the flavor of the meat.
But what is the universal, I hijacked your show,
but what is the unit?
What is the unifying thing that comedians,
UFC, fighters and hunters all have in common?
It's difficult. We're doing difficult things. That pretty unifying thing. Yeah.
This is difficult pursuit.
Self-Appointed yet comedy is an extremely difficult pursuit.
The idea of taking an idea, crafting it, and then distributing unit,
performing it in front of people
who paid money to hear you talk when they can talk to you got to pay money.
You're not, you're not doing, there's an audacity. Yeah, you're not doing flips.
You don't have a fucking multimedia show. There's no pyrotechnics.
But you're just talking and people will pay money,
get a babysitter dry and you've got to make sure it's right man.
Cause they'll get fucking angry at you is there's a direct correlation between
how happy people are when you make them laugh versus how angry they are if you
don't make them lie the way I believe that, you know,
people talk and my tickets are or are not high or anything.
But I think people care more about their time than they do about the money. Yes.
It's like, cause if you're a parent, you're like, I got this is my one night.
Yeah. It better be good. Yes. Yes. It's like,
it's like when you go to a restaurant and you're like, really this is my entree.
You know what I mean? Granted I eat out every night, but um, but,
but I used to be healthy when I used to be healthy and I'd have that burger like
once a month you'd be like,
this is my burger and it's fat shitty. Now I have like two burgers a day.
Yeah. And it's like I'm always happy. Well that's good. That's good.
But the thing they have in common is that they're all difficult things.
[inaudible]
incredibly difficult. E there's no bullshit in martial arts.
You have to hit someone that you don't either hit you or they don't.
You either win or you don't.
It's like it's really cut and dry and it's just a matter of how much effort you
put into it, how much you've learned, your craft,
how much you've recognized your weaknesses and shored up your holes and your
defense and your offense and then you execute when you have to.
Which is means like when it's time for a fight, you perform,
you rise to the occasion or you don't. Very similar to going on stage,
not with the same consequences but very similar in terms of like rising to the
occasion.
Is it something you have to be, you have to like stand up.
You have to be doing it like it's not, you know, Eddie Murphy is amazing,
but the reason he didn't just pop back into doing standup is he understands I
target like, like I'm friends with him,
but he understands you have to do it often too. I mean, that's,
by the way, Chris Rock,
amazing that he literally took like 10 years off and then got back into the
ritual and the cause. It's a commitment.
There's nothing really that fancy about it,
but like when it comes to UFC, Eh, you have to,
you can't just pick it up, right? But hunting, you can pick it up, right?
Or No, you can pick up some kinds of hunting, right? Like you could, you could
pick up rifle hunting for certain animals.
All you'd have to do is understand how to keep your breath under control,
how to not flinch when you pull a trigger, how to aim,
how to use a weapon properly and have someone that puts you in a good position
where you know you have a guide, maybe that helps to bring you along.
Bow Hunting is a another level of commitment that requires athleticism.
You're most likely going to have be in really good shape
because you're going to have to go into the mountains and just the altitude
alone and then going climbing up hills. You're going up several up and down,
several thousand feet of elevation in a day. And there are grocery stores,
there's grocery stores, grocery stores that serve wild up shocked yourself.
Fascinating Facet. I think it could sometimes I'll look at,
you know, the, the, the community of Comedians, which I truly enjoy.
I re and you obviously do too. Yeah.
It's like you'll sometimes run into other communities that cause there is this
solitary nature to it. And then there's this shared obsession.
Like I sometimes feel like chefs or people that,
you know,
just even cooks that really get true enjoyment out of it are have that shared
kind of, you know, like you the prep time, the kind of, uh,
you're doing it for yourself. Like, you know,
a chef will come to the table and say, do you like your meal?
But they don't need someone to approve it. They know.
So it's like with stand up, it's, it's the respect of your peers too.
It's like, it's great. It's gratifying the audience liking it.
But there is something about the creation of the material that is so profoundly,
uh, uh, approving.
And the also the feedback that you get from an audience that is separate from
like the supposed fame, dare you put an alarm. I know.
What are you trying to do? I that's, that's, that means it's time to eat. Help.
Yeah. No,
I mean I think many communities that are like important communities have, uh,
are important to the people involved. They have like,
they share a lot of common aspects, whether it's comedians or, I mean,
I think anything that's difficult, right? If there's not,
like when you think about Comedians, there's not that many of us.
If you really stop to think about there's 300 million people in this country,
how many professional comedians is there? Even a thousand. I mean,
how many people are really making a living off of just doing stand up? I mean,
I would venture that might be about 250,
which is amazing because by the way, when I started and uh,
and you're around the same period it was, there was like nobody,
there was no, and by the way and Seinfeld's era, there was even less, nobody,
Lenny Bruce's era there was like him. And Mort Sahl and like one other guy.
Yeah. Yeah. Insane. Insane and saying,
but now there's like professors. Yeah, let's stand up.
[inaudible] they're all ridiculous.
I interviewed one guy and he wrote a book on Kaleo.
Well that's ridiculous ideas really. I think that uh,
I think that stand up when people,
it's like when we try and figure out why a joke works so that we can figure out
how to do another one, we lose it. Like there is some magic,
there's some magic not to get too, there is something of like,
there's a moment, you know like sometimes singer songwriters talk about this,
that like a song just appears and some of it is we put in the time and we,
we put in the work on ourselves and kind of like self reflection and we're open
to understanding who our point of view is and we're embracing our embarrassment.
That kind of opens us to material.
Yeah. Then there's also, the more you do it in, the more frequently you do it,
the more you kind of have a feel for it. And when you take time off,
that's when it's really weird. Like for me,
I went on vacation recently to Italy and then I went back on stage after like 12
days and I was like, Whoa, do I know how to do this weird feeling until we,
oh yeah, you gotta be immersed in it all the time.
But I also think it's great to take those little vacation. Oh,
you get a great perspective. [inaudible] yeah.
It's like suddenly you come back and you, you find the piece to the puzzle.
You make it work, you need like little breaks.
But I think that's the case with virtually everything that we all need
perspective and you need discipline and you need the work ethic to do all,
to put all the time in and do all the work.
But you also need to think clearly and you need an enthusiasm.
And sometimes that like it's intelligent and it's disciplined to take a break.
Yeah, it is. It's, I find it hard.
I mean I also like I'm somebody who,
like I always arrive in a market with an hour of new material,
but, and I have,
there's plenty of people that they do a special and then they take a break and
they uh, hang out and they might kind of slowly develop more material.
And to me that is,
I dunno if that's am on both sides of it. I understand the value of it,
but I also, there's, I don't,
I don't have control of when the stuff's gonna come out. So I kind of want,
I want to be paying attention when the material comes out cause sometimes,
you know, the comedians all have this,
it's like you had a great idea but you didn't reach over for your phone when you
were falling asleep.
It's gone. It's gone. Yeah. That's, I jump up,
I'll, I'll put,
I'll plug my ears and run out of the room if my wife and kids are talking.
If I was like, yeah, I used to not, I used to not idea,
but my wife is awesome about it. Like shit, I'll just go.
I have an idea and I just have to say it to her so she doesn't think I'm just
playing with my phone while we're at dinner. I just go, I've got an idea.
She'll let me chill. Let me do that. But you have to do that.
If you don't do that, those things slip away. They're like a salmon in a river.
Like grab it, grab it. That's right. And it's gone. The bear. We are the bear.
And then the elk is watching and then Joe shoots the elk and the idea guys,
what does an elk sound like? Like that bird
like 500 pounds. And what are they just, are they vegetarian? Yes. Yeah,
they're vegetarians. And what about a bear? Have you ever shot a bear? Yes.
You've been to a brown bear. Black bear. They're very good.
They taste good, and you have to shoot him. Otherwise they eat everything.
They eat each other, they eat all the elk babies, they eat all the deer babies.
50% of all elk and deer, Fonz,
r a l l calves and deer fawns are eaten by bears.
50% wow. Yeah, they devastate populations, but it's a balance of life.
You know what I mean? It's the circle of love. Yes, but it's a balance.
It's like you have to, there has to be some control predators. Yeah.
It's so interesting. So interesting.
It's a wild world and I've been involved in it since like 2012 that's when I
really got into. When you were growing up, you were,
did you hunt for when you were a kid? I did a lot of fishing.
And where did you grow up? Well, I was born in New Jersey, but a,
I lived a lot of places.
I lived down in San Francisco for a while from age seven to 11 I lived in
Florida from 11 to 13 and then Boston from 13 to 24 then New York.
Then I was in nature or nurture.
Are you because of you because of life experience or were you born like this?
I think there's a little bit of both for sure. And also some of it is, you know,
you've been on this self, you know,
I feel like characterizing this as an insult, but it's not.
But you are somebody who's like, I'm going to self-improve myself.
I tried to do that all the time. Mentally, physically, everything. Looking buff.
I think you can always do better. Right.
And so how do you find out if you can do better? What's that?
Your mentality? Was that your mentality in your early twenties yeah.
Then it came from martial arts. Cause if you, if you don't try to get better,
you wind up getting fucked up. Like as dangerous. Like you get hurt. You know?
Cause I grew up from, from high school,
from the time I was 15 until I was 21 all I did was travel the country and
fight. I competed with Mr Miyagi. No, he wasn't around back then.
But that's, that's really what I did. That's all he did. And so that,
the mentality had to be constantly looking to improve,
figuring out what you're doing wrong and figuring out how to do better and,
and being brutally honest about your strengths and weaknesses.
Oh yeah, we'll be right back.
It's a weird transition from that in the stand up comedy, you know?
But I think there's some parallels.
There's some parallels because bombing on stage is one of, I've lost fights,
but bombing on stage might feel worse.
It might be the worst feeling you could ever feel other than like physical pain.
Yeah, he know there is something about it.
I always think it's weird when people will say, oh, I could never do that.
And in some ways I think comedians we forget because there are,
particularly at the beginning there at dark days, there are levels,
humiliation
that most normal people would go, don't ever do this.
But comedians are such lunatics that they're like,
that's fine, that's fine. And by the way,
what they don't realize is there's some of us that break through and we can kind
of figure it out, but there are some people that try stand up,
fail miserably, have the perseverance, and never get better.
That's true. It's brutal. There's certain,
there's a certain mindset that never improves and I don't know what that is.
I don't know if it's a genetic thing.
If it's a lack of a brain horsepower,
there's certain people that just never get it. They never get it.
And they try and they don't and they just, they never,
they never figured their way through. And there is also something about,
I have a big belief that comedy changes just as we were talking about,
you know,
there's a difference between political correctness and like there is a,
um,
a cultural trend that's almost kind of looking for someone making a mistake that
it's shifted every, I, I call it decades.
So like there is a, uh, in the 80s,
the, uh, you know, at the peak of kind of Seinfeld stand up,
which transformed into his show.
He didn't need to provide any autobiographical information.
It was just jokes and there was also, um,
and it was even Carlin at his peak, he, he wasn't, he,
he would provide some, he was grounded in authenticity, but it wasn't like,
uh, you know, I struggle with whether I'm a good dad or not. It was,
but in this day and age, there is, we're,
we're such an exhibitionist and voyeuristic culture that there is a requirement
of that where I think that when I watch stand up and you know,
and by the way, I also believe that when people go, all my stories,
everything's true. That's true. It's like it's not true. It's, it's, it's,
it's inspired by truth, but,
but authenticity is so important.
So when you hear a comedian say my girlfriend or my father,
and it's not true,
like that could have worked in the 80s but I think now the authenticity is the
audience is like, oh, that's a great joke,
but that's not your girlfriend or your dad or your brother or like,
do you know what I'm saying? Yeah. You have to.
Maybe if you are like a real absurdist and like it is obvious you're lying about
everything and that's part of the joke. Oh yeah, yeah. Other than that, yeah.
If you just make up a story. And by the way,
I also think that in 10 years it might be all light,
but like now in this Kardashians kind of reality
show era, people want to see a little bit behind that. You know?
I mean I think that whether it's a
Bert or Sagura,
there's these stories that people relish in their lives in seeing their lives
and sharing the experience. And,
and that's something that wasn't necessarily, uh,
prevalent or maybe I'm just talking out my ass. No, no, I think you're right.
I mean, I think we didn't really know much about comics back in that day.
We just know about their, I mean prior did this 40 years ago,
but he was an anomaly. He was, he was, you know,
so unique.
And wouldn't it be amazing to see prior back then on a podcast like see Pryor
and gene wilder sitting down just shooting the shit for hours.
It was an incredible, unbelievable. It's, it's,
I don't remember when I saw when I, you know,
it was deep into stand up maybe like eight years and I went and consumed prior
stuff again after, you know, being in the business.
It was so shocking how much had been stolen from him.
Like entire acts. You're like, oh my gosh, yeah. You know,
that's in so and so special that's in, you know,
every comedian that comes from a certain area does these jokes and it was like,
he was really revolutionary on so many different levels. Forget the,
the true gift of like, uh,
being funny and autobiographical and kind of vulnerable.
Like people don't realize that like when he did that show in Long Beach,
it's like any open for Patti labelle like,
and people were coming in at the beginning. It's like, yeah,
that's absurd that someone that was someone special.
Do you remember when he was doing that special in Long Beach and there was a guy
who walked up right to the stage with a camera. He's like,
get the fuck Outta here, man. Go sit down. And he left that in there.
I left it in the end. And by the way,
people have to understand that that wasn't, you know,
half those people were not, they were there to see Patti labelle. Yeah. Like,
that's really amazing. Yeah. Like that super talent that's like,
you know, like, and I think Chappelle has that [inaudible] it's like just,
you know, I don't know. It's like a,
almost like a level of genius where he is almost kind of like,
I'm going to set up a hurdle for myself. Yeah. It's absurd. Well, shit,
it makes me also constantly working, man.
Like he just popped into the belly room, uh, two nights ago, just showed up,
does a set in the belly room two does a set in the, in the main room,
goes over to the Improv, constantly hopping around. You know,
I've told this story before, but it's a, it's a crazy one. I was in Denver,
I was doing the comedy works and it's a Friday night at 10 o'clock show I get
done. I go into the green room, Dave's there. I go, what are you doing man?
He goes, oh, what's up Joe?
I was just, I decided to come by like he decided to come by,
meaning he flew into Denver on a private jet with no show set up because he knew
that I was going to be there and wanting to do a set.
So he just does what he wants. Like it just shows up when I go,
do you want to go up? He goes, Oh shit. I go, fuck it. Hold on a second.
I run back on stage. I tell the audience, I go, come back,
sit down Dave Chappelle's here. They're like, what?
And so everybody comes back in and sits down. I go, ladies and gentlemen,
please welcome Dave Chappelle. He goes up and does 40 minutes just free,
just does it. But he's just doing that all the time. It's not all for money.
It's all for the craft. It's all for performing, working out.
The material just travels around and does these things and just shows us.
He does like 18 shows at the Warner just shows half weeks.
Just does this is always, always on top of it, you know?
And that is why it's not just his, his,
his obvious talent and his brilliance, but also his work ethic.
All those things combined. It's, there's not one without the other.
You don't just get the guy who takes six months off and he's just brilliant
always. And you wake him up and he's got the best set ever. No,
it's like he's constantly grinding constantly.
And I think with our s with this art form that we do, it requires diligence.
It requires maintenance. It is totally diligent. Yeah.
Do you write on paper? Do you write on a laptop?
I do. I don't even have my stuff here, but I'm always putting stuff down.
But like I, uh, you know, some of it's bits and nubs, you know,
like these are notes from like Ireland. I mean,
I love being in other cultures cause I not only do you see the eccentric side of
their culture, but it also exposes how absurd our culture is.
But yeah, no, it's, some of it is just, and also, you know, it's just,
uh, just absurd. You know,
it's like also in another country as opposed to cities.
It's so different. And I am an American so I,
I can just kind of hoarse around for 10 minutes and sometimes I'm doing the
equivalent of like the subway joke, you know,
like when people would come to New York and go like,
I was on the subway and you're like, don't do that. But when I'm like in Spain,
I'm like, you know what, I'm probably doing the equivalent of a subway joke.
But they appreciate the research and I really do.
I do. I am fascinated by other cultures and I am fascinating, you know,
and kind of observing different things and understanding the history.
It's kind of like,
I think that like visiting other countries is kind of similar to talking to like
a, a really drunk, angry guy.
Like if you're talking to a drunk angry guy and you're like, I understand you.
I understand that.
Like for 400 years the English didn't let you make cheese.
Like the drunk angry guys. Yeah. Thank you for understanding that you're,
I mean, and that's, you know, they're not asking for it, but it's fun.
So do you mostly just write down notes and then work those notes out on out on
stage? Yeah, some of it it's, you know, like when I was in Ireland,
uh, and I, I s I went to a Donegall, which I love and I, what is Donnie Gall?
It's a county in the Northwestern part of the republic that should be part of
Northern Ireland, but it was so Catholic, uh, that the British really, you know,
you guys can keep that one like it's way up there and it's kind of um,
relatively isolated. So there's,
there's not American tourists.
It's really kind of just people that live there. And uh,
I spend a week and then I did a show in Letterkenny and um,
and I kinda was like picking on them, but it was not, you know,
not the roasting form, but it was just, you know,
cause it's all Gail talk, you know, like they speak Gaelic. That's so weird.
What does it sound like? It sounds nothing like English. It's,
it's really weird cause it's, you know,
it doesn't have some English sounds in it. I'm not really, well,
there'll be an English word that they'll just,
I think they add a sheen to the end of an English word. They're like, oh,
you have to go to the airport itching. And you're like,
well that's what I can barely under. It's kind of like the Scottish,
I can barely understand when they're speaking English, but I loved it.
Northern Islands. Very interesting in that regard. I was in northern,
I was in Belfast and uh, listening to people that were drunk talk. Oh yeah.
You might as well been on another planet. Well, by the way, those,
the British isles, including a of the Republic of Ireland,
there is something so tribal there,
like there's something really interesting as an American that, you know,
we have this cute notion of like, I am Irish, I, Hey, I drink too much.
Whereas like the, uh,
the Irish and the English and the Scottish and the Welsh,
there is something that is there.
It kind of comes out of 11 o'clock at night. You're like,
you'll see a different side. Like I was at this,
I was at this House party in Donegall and the next day I ran into the guy who
goes and there was probably 10 adults there. He's like, catch him.
We drank 29 glasses, 21 nine bottles of wine. And I'm like, what,
29. And I know that I may be drank one of them,
but not, I don't think all the adults drank. You know, by the way in Ireland,
not everyone drinks. It's just the people that do drink really do it.
Yeah. So there's like, I think someone told me the percentage of,
uh, you know,
Irish that drink is smaller than the rest of Europe,
but the percentage that do drink and um, I can't even remember was,
I remember what I going to say, but it's just,
I could talk about Ireland forever cause it's so fast. Oh,
but around 11 o'clock at night, there's something that happens. And this,
by the way, this guy was not drunk, but I was at this cocktail party,
this dinner party, and the kids are, everyone has five kids.
So there's like five kids, there's 400 kids in the backyard.
And this guy's just railing into me. He's like, he's like, you're, you know,
the media has already decided that it's Kamela Harris. How can you decide that?
And I'm like, wait a minute. I'm like, first of all, what are you talking about?
And he just consumes. He's doing all this research and this guy, you know,
uh, but he's convinced. He goes, it's camel Harris, the media, big Bro. Uh,
big brothers have decided it's Kamilah Harris. And I'm like, whoa.
And it's just fascinating, but it's, how do they know?
We don't know a fucking goddamn thing about their people. The, the,
some of it is, and by the way, people were kind of, how do you know this?
And some of it, but I bring that up because there was a behind,
it was this tribalism kind of like this. Um,
you know, and obviously the Irish are very different than the English,
but there was something about this that was, um,
you know, you, you see it a little bit, you know, uh,
with southerners that are kind of like,
we're going to give you hell kind of thing. But like, and I've see it,
you see it in England all the time, like 11 o'clock. You're like,
what happened to like Hugh Grant? You know,
it's just like a different world. Well,
once they abandoned all the, the niceties, you get to see who they really, yeah,
yeah. With a couple of pints home to, it's super authentic,
but it's also like that culture, and I know that you're the,
but like the whole like, oh, you know,
what would be fun is to go out and drink a bunch of pints and then we'll get in
a fight. Like, to me, that sounds horrible, but you would like that,
wouldn't you? No, no. I'm not interested in bar fights.
I think it's a terrible idea. That's how people die. People get crippled.
But people do that all the time. I saw Andy Dick guns conscious.
Did you see that? Oh Man. Yeah. I just saw that video.
It's really fucked up. Um, I'll send it to you. I hope he's all right.
He's definitely not all right. He's a frail little fella.
You got to get out of here. I do. Oh, that's a car. I'm waiting for you.
I was wondering what's, I have a meeting. What do you happen? What's going on?
You're a fucking moving around in a shaker.
You're applying or out here in Holly and no, I'm not at all.
But like I have this meeting of, uh, you know, for a TV show.
It's a big producer meeting, but it is you. The last question that you do,
you do, is it hard for you to balance,
because I know you've done a lot of acting gigs, but I know you love standup.
Is it hard for you to find like the time balance? It's,
it's different because I love standup. I am a standup.
It's something that I'll have to do. I'm sure it's the same with you.
It's like it, you're gonna do it until you die. Yes.
I think some people are like, I can't believe Seinfeld went back to standup.
I'm like, of course he did. He's a comedian,
but the acting is something that I love,
but I don't view it as an income source.
He viewed it as a live view. It as it's, it's,
it's something that, and by the way, you're a good actor. Thank you. I love it.
I love playing a character. I love playing a bad guy. I love kind of,
it seems fun justifying, you know, every actor wants to play someone flawed,
but I love playing these people that you don't have any sense of doubt why
you're doing something in a scene. Like you're like, this is all I can do.
And afterwards,
I love the moment when you're at craft service and there's somebody that looks
at you like the character, they're like, Huh? You know, I mean I usually,
I used to play it a lot of nerds,
so people would be like dismissive of me and annoyed that I'm like, look,
I'm not the character,
but I love it when I'm playing someone who's kind of doing something maniacal.
And people were like, why would you do that? Oh look,
I'm just playing a guy that would condemn somebody. I'm not going to kidnap you.
I enjoy that kind of stuff, but I just, I do too many things as it is. So I've,
I've kind of sworn off all acting. Really? Yeah. Bam.
And at a couple of years ago, what if it was the perfect role? I mean, it's,
it's highly inefficient, but I just think it's so fun.
Like I sent you that link to the movie and I want you to watch it because I
think if you watch it, you're going to go, oh, I get it. Oh, I do get it.
I get it. I just can't do it. But it's like, that was like, uh,
I remember that was like three weeks and every, you know,
on weekends I had shows it was really inefficient. It was all night shoots.
It was utter insanity. But you're happy with the result.
But that's one of those were worked.
There were more experienced in life in general that I think enhances your stand
up. And I think it's difficult for us to look at it that way,
but I think the more different things you do,
the more different experiences that you have,
the more your perspective gets enhanced. And there's,
there's moments that are almost paralleled that, you know,
obviously as a comedian, we love the laughs and we love kind of creating,
changing someone's mood and similar to, you know,
alleviating the attention and stand up and acting like sitting in that tension
and just kind of twisting the knife and the audience.
It's kind of exhilarating and something unique that you only going to get an
acting. Yes. Yeah. Yeah. Jim Gaffigan, you're a bad motherfucker.
Please tell everybody when your new special drops Friday is Friday,
I think Friday the 16th what is today? Wednesday? Yes. You have two days folks.
Two days, two days. But they can add it to their watch list.
But next time you go to Amazon to buy your paper towels, your socks,
just check it out. Checking out bitches please. Thank you, sir. Thank you.
Pleasure. Thank you. Thanks for nicotine gum too. Now I'm addicted.
I totally.